certains ont trouvé ce délire un peu bof
je le conçois j'accepte mon sort en ce
moment j'ai un délire que beaucoup
d'autres gens ont eu avant moi mais je
vieillis et du coup je découvre ses
délires que d'autres genres lui avancer
les origines des expressions des
expressions de la langue bas les
nouveaux mots georges et le somme où ce
truc papa ça vraiment les expressions
qu'on fait ça m'intéresse parce qu'en
gros la langue française et vous
c'est fou squeeze tu parle la langue
française mais on est où là
à quoi que attendez on a un passif avec
allart est ok tu connais toi à l'arrêt
alors ça m'a répondu qu'il mène au
maintien justement parlé d'un arrêt à
l'arrêt son délire ces mots quels sont
les nouveaux mots utilisés dans le
langage courant français est ce qu'ils
doivent rentrer dans le dictionnaire oui
non quels sont les mots qui ne sont plus
utilisés quels aspects de la langue ont
changé par exemple nous on aime beaucoup
faire des contractions alors qu'on avait
beaucoup moins van bon bref je suis pas
un pro des langues mais elle ça c'est
ride à l'arrêt et moi aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler de georges planel c'est
un mec qui a eu la même réflexion que
moi aujourd'hui comme les expressions
des fois c'est bizarre par exemple
pourquoi on dit se prendre un râteau
si vous prenez le sens des mots tels
qu'il est comme ça ça veut rien dire
donc historiquement comment on en est
arrivé à dire ça dans cette situation
pas comme j'ai dis lui s'est fait cette
réflexion là 14 en 2005 il a créé le
site et pression qui illustrent toutes
les expressions de la langue française
et leur définition étant attirés par ce
truc de signification d'expression j'ai
demandé à l'oreille de nous concocter un
petit quizz que je vais faire seul et
vous allez faire avec moi en même temps
aurait la page des liens ont fait en
même temps on va devoir trouver le sens
de 18 expression et pour chaque
expression il y aura quatre choix
possible bref
allons-y on commence avec se prendre un
râteau justement se prendre un râteau du
coup est ce que c'est un dérivé du mot
raté se prendre la manche du râteau en
marchant dessus ça a dû arriver à un mec
dans l'histoire de l'humanité pas plus
ça vient de la tradition du troc et de
l' échange aa hockey genre d'échangé un
truc de valeur et tu l'as eu contre un
râteau et le râteau c'est genre le truc
un peu nul est pourri dans les changes à
l'époque je sais pas bah voilà pourquoi
j'adore le râteau fait référence aux
barreaux d'une prison est bien la
première question je suis je suis bloqué
net c'est ça qui est cool j prendre un
instant pour réfléchir
[Musique]
et mes actes et j'ai envie de croire à
la théorie du cse prendre le manche du
râteau en marchant dessus parce que ça
se trouve il ya une époque de bessan
d'humanité où ça arrive et mega souvent
j'ai envie d'y croire
ah non la vie de ma mère cfa je sais ce
que je vous ai dit c'était la méga
longtemps la plupart des gens
travaillaient dans les champs et du coup
il t'arrive est des fois de pas voir
karato été posée de marché sur le bout
et te prendre le manche si génial alors
se faire alpaguer la mecque assez chaude
un argot dérivés d'attraper provient de
l'animal
alpaga à c'est tout parce qu'on peut
croire à tous en fait tout est crédible
j'ai bien joué lorraine ça se trouve
l'alpaga c'est un petit animal tu te
balades en forêt comme ça au petit tombe
dessus qui clamèrent comme ça
immédiatement et du coup dans la rue
quand un mec te tombe dessus et fait
chier et ben eh ben ils talent pag c'est
ça je lis pas les autres c'est ça c'est
sûr je hais les quiz
regardez ces extraits de moments où je
me fais chier sur des quizz car je
déteste ça là j'adore makes alors
attends l'alpaga hommes et 6 1 milliards
j'ai honte j'ai honte je visualise très
bien ce animal mais je savais pas que ça
plaît en allemagne afin ggp a percuté
nous avons donc l'alpaga qui est un
tissu constitué de l'aisne de l'animal
du même nom qu'est par métonymie à mot
utilisé pour expliquer ce mot dont je
n'ai déjà pas le sens puisqu'on met son
manteau sur son dos lorsqu'on les enfile
pour sortir le mot à d'abord désigné le
dos on utilisait d'ailleurs à l'époque
des expressions comme tomber sur
l'alpage similaire à tomber sur le dos
pour s'en prendre à nous attaquer ok
donc en gros il dit ah [ __ ] il lui est
tombé sur le dos on disait il est tombé
sur la vague et ensuite on disait il l'a
alpagué c'est marrant ces étapes
j'adore est donc là c'est lié au
contexte dont je vous parlais du coup le
fait qu'à une époque on utilisait de ouf
la laine d'alpaga pour faire des
vêtements bref au [ __ ] au ras des
pâquerettes
elle est géniale salle au ras des
pâquerettes ça veut dire sans intérêts
sans envergure c'est au ras des
pâquerettes ce qu'il a fait c'est
minable
alors tire son origine de la fête de
pâques et de la fin d'un cycle argo des
jardiniers quand la saison est bientôt
fini or il est dur mec vient de la
petite taille des pâquerettes mais
pourquoi ça veut dire minable ah ok si
peut-être que c'est une manière de dire
il a fait un truc petit et donc comme
les pâquerettes c'est petit c'est ça
c'est la nature mais [ __ ] mais je suis
en poste wahou quel plaisir pour une
fois des bons à un quiz
attendez je fais trois questions à
friser le ridicule donc fraiser ridicule
c'est a frôlé le ridicule c'était pas
loin du ridicule
c'est quoi ça provient des perruques à
bouclettes utilisés dans les pièces de
molière c'est un dérivé du verbe frôlait
origine inconnue une référence aux
thermes frij in love c'est quoi j'ai
envie d'arrêter et de rester sur mes
trois victoires c'est le même dilemme
que pat a fait 3 game le soir des états
allaient dormir tant phelps quatrième tu
perds la quatrième voiture par sur 5e
immédiatement frisé mike c'est vraiment
je me suis friser les cheveux ses jeux
ses rotations quoi je pense que c'est un
truc par rapport aux perruques dans les
pièces de molière référence au verbe
frau libre futenma gueule vert frisé le
même sens que frôler ou effleuré soit
passé de très près à proximité immédiate
ohlala sur city 10 car s'il n'y a aucun
doute sur le sens du ridicule le verbe
frisé lui n'a rien à voir avec les
bigoudis genre vraiment quand t'es con
tu dit messier par rapport aux cheveux
frisés hockey entré comme dans un moulin
alors celui-là mais qu il aimait diaconu
à la barre on y entre comme dans un
moulin
euh y'a aucune ce qu on attend ça c'est
pas moi qui me tient qu'à c'est le vrai
moi que je renie et secrètement mais
c'est le vraiment à la gauche network au
xvième siècle la plupart des moulins
étaient publiques accessibles à tout le
village
ben c'est ça l'expression complète est
entré comme un homme dans un moulin
référence alors que tu étais tu es leurs
habitudes à se promener partout en
lorraine n'aurait jamais trouvé ça
n'aurait jamais trouvé sa seule c'est
beaucoup trop dur à inventer ou alors
métaphore de l'eau qui revendent dans le
moulin et on ressort librement non non
je pensais non je pense c'est le truc de
l'amc lorraine écoute moi bien c'est à
trouver ça tu étais trop forte
je suis au dieu parce que là je suis
allé par déduction par rapport au
potentiel de mon ami à créer des fausses
réponses
je suis à maffre personnages à tour de
rôle [ __ ] si j en quoi ces vents des
expressions très fréquente en fait
allez-vous donner vos prénoms à tour de
rôle provient du latin médiéval recul us
qui désigne un parchemin rouler où
étaient inscrits des noms attend sait
parfaitement ce que je sais ça jeudi un
exemple au pif
et comme par hasard ya une histoire de
noms dans l'explication à tant honni
quand même les autres origines
théâtrales où les comédiens en petit
effectif effectué plusieurs rôles sur
scène chacun leur tour en référence à
une course de vélo autour du lac du rôle
en ardèche
j'y crois très peu quelqu'un inventé
cette expression et on sait pas pourquoi
au lac la semec j'aimerais trois
antennes expression et elle rentre dans
le langage courant de tout le monde
c'est incroyable
moi je trouve que le délai où je donne
un exemple je parle de prénom au mais ça
se trouve c'est lauren kim brain ça se
trouve c'est lauren qui est trop malines
elle sait que la tour de rôle la faute
entendu l'expression à tour de rôle
c'est ton professeur condé vous faites
si à tour de rôle ça vient du latin
médiéval rotule us qui désignait un
parchemin rouler où étaient inscrits des
noms je pense que j'ai envie d'y croire
quelle chance je suis un chat
grosso modo whaou savoir l'origine de çà
c'est équivalent à savoir pourquoi
l'humain et sur terre c'est celle là
mais c'est le même niveau de réponse
existentielle dont j'ai besoin c'est
chelou et ça vient de l'italien qui
signifie en général mais non ça aurait
été grossis mondiaux c'est aussi ça
vient de l'histoire de quasimodo qui
sonnait les grosses cloches des grosso
modo provient d'un plat traditionnel
alpin qui se cuisine est dans une grande
marmite du latin médiéval signifiant de
manière grossière lorraine en tout cas
sachez une chose c'est que tu es
extrêmement fortes dans tes réponses
après t'as pas de chance parce que moi
je suis très talentueux alors du coup
direct et réponses sont pour moi c'est
latin médiéval signifiant de manière
grossière sur mais voilà non mais
attendez quand est-ce qu'on fait diriger
un dictionnaire mois alain jarry se
lever du pied gauche
donc ce levé du mauvais pied quoi sa
cinquantaine mauvaise humeur impossible
mais c'est pas mais au cas où tout
simplement une superstition référence de
personnes qu'on appelait les pieds
gauche qualifie ainsi après amputés et
donc après avoir passé une sale journée
ça va loin tire son origine du fait que
la plupart des gens sont droitiers que
par conséquent celui du pied gauche
c'est mal commencé sa journée pour un
droitier à métaphore de la guerre où
l'on passe l'armé à gauche en cas de
décès ah oui ok passer la main gauche
c'est une expression qui veut dire il
est mort j'ai envie de croire au truc du
c'est mal commencé sa journée pour un
droitier mais j'ai besoin que c'est
débile
j'ai besoin qu'il faut être sacrément
con pour cliquer là dessus c'est raccord
ouais ça vous fait rire de faire des
expressions sur les gauchers à la
machine tu club avec peuplé gauche alors
que tout ton pied d'appui c'est le droit
et lita mais en fait alors pleuré comme
une madeleine
alors là le piège de l'est le piège de
bédié au moins une question là dans
laquelle vous choisirez la réponse du
tibet c'est pas grave on est tous dans
cette situation vous allez bien le vivre
là tu penses à la madeleine genre qui se
mange à le matin mais en fait la
madeleine c'est il ya un autre sens mais
je vais le trouver en lisant réponse ça
vient du fait que la cuisson une
madeleine des gorges beaucoup d'eau je
connais rien à la cuisine se tire son
origine de la bible et plus précisément
de marie madeleine qui a pleuré pour
laver ses péchés voilà c'est ça allez
hop c'est cuit qu'elle soit valide et on
en parle plus suivant chez aux teintes
oui je suis autant faire un carton de
quel objet animal cette expression
provient tél il ya des images
le carton rouge c'est sûr c'est la
réponse des cons je le sais parce que
j'avais envie de mettre sa est ce qu'à
l'époque faire un carton c'était réussir
à mettre un certain nombre de balle bien
placée sur une cible ou un truc comme ça
ou alors faire un carton genre elle est
la brocante il a fait un carton entier
tête avant il y avait le mot antilles et
genre il a vendu l'équivalent de tout ce
qu'ils avaient dans un carton j'ai envie
croire la tournée du carton à faire un
carton c'est thierry sur une cible sur
une meilleure personne remporté un grand
succès une nette victoire car ce n est
qu une forme dérivée de notre expression
qui s'utilise avec les 200 syndiqués il
a aussi voulu dire jouer aux cartes
comme tamesna carrés doit pouvoir
apparaître le shérif sur une cible sur
quelqu'un passe un tour manager inquiet
dans canal ok donc quand a cartonné ça
veut dire que tu as réussi à toucher le
carton et que donc dans le cadre d'une
complète il ya des chances pour que tes
remporter la victoire
voilà le marchand de sable est passé ton
vient du fait qu'on disait avoir du
sable dans les yeux pour dire qu'on
avait sommeil ou les yeux qui piquaient
sous l'effet de la fatigue
je crois que c'est ça expression tout
simplement sorti d'un livre pour enfants
du xviie siècle hockey légende dont
personne ne connaît vraiment l'origine
hockey métaphore sur la société où tout
ce marchand de même le sommeil moi même
si elle pas trop pas le jour où tu dis
c'est parce que les yeux sont mal
hydrater quand tu es fatigué du coup ça
pique
c'est sûr c'est ça ben voilà suivants
avoir la patate
yes la patate est connu pour être un bon
apport énergétique faux vers les
cultivateurs de pommes de terre qui
devait se lever très tôt pour travailler
faut au début du 20e siècle la pomme de
terre donc la patate est assimilé à la
tête et donc avoir la patate voulait
dire avoir une bonne tête
la pomme de terre est un élément utilisé
quasiment à chaque repas et donc par
conséquent très présent quelqu'un qui a
la patate est présent et on le remarque
un spa con c'est pas con mais je connais
leur aide je me fie que sur ce que je
sais de lorraine café le quiz c'est
horrible moi j'ai envie de croire au
truc du la patate c'était assimilé à la
tête genre comme la poire est une bonne
poire tôt aujourd'hui
cette avance était est une bonne patate
tôt aujourd'hui
allez j'y crois propos au pont bon
[ __ ] c'est fou comme je suis content
alors que je sais rien de fou un boute
en train
ah ouais alors attends je sais même plus
ça veut dire une personne qui excite à
la joie ou amusé avec lesquels elles se
trouvent
voilà c'est ça un boute-en-train hockey
atteint sans même regarder c'est pas
parce que à l'époque dans les trains
laso il y avait une zone spécifique où
tu avais droit de faire du bruit par
l'effort de rire et même d'aller dans
cette zone a dans ce but là et c'était
genre le dernier wagon donc le bout du
train vient du verbe août et qui
signifie mettre en train de bonne humeur
tire son nom des clowns présent dans
certains trains sncf pour dit vous
faites plus à etsaut les clowns dans les
trains mot d'origine anglaise boot pour
qualifier les grandes chaussures des
bouffons du roi métaphore du goût du
train le dernier wagon qui est toujours
le dernier à faire une vanne
je sais ça je pense j'ai choisi une
réponse qui voulait rien dire
judy donc boudent vient bien du verbe
goûter qui veut dire m mais train n'a
rien à voir la sncf au xviie siècle en
train voulait dire en action en
mouvement à la même époque être en train
signifie aussi être dans de bonnes
dispositions physiques ou psychiques
ça veut donc littéralement dire mettre
de bonne humeur joyeuse quoi avoir la
gueule de bois
celui-là mec je veux trop l'avoir tire
son nom de la dureté slash poids d'un
arbre qui colle donc avec la tête lourde
d'un lendemain de soirée
ok la gueule désigne la bouche devenu
aussi sèche que dubois nom vient d'un
alcool des corses absolument immonde
mais qui servait de digestif
après le repas expression du xviie
siècle où certaines soirées trop
arrosées finissez dehors voire dans les
tas de bois à côté il y croirait le gall
acteurs on le fait dans le tas brindis
juste là non la gueule désigne la bouche
aussi sage que du bois
j'aurais jamais nous a raconté des
salades c'est raconter de bêtises que
alors en jardinage les salades sont
parfois un tag de l'extérieur mais une
fois cueillies se révèle pourri les
salades cachent souvent des petits
verres caché entre les feuilles la
salade est traditionnement servi en fin
de repas là où les esprits sont plus
vulnérables et les invités un peu
pompette prêt à raconter tout et
n'importe quoi voilà salades c'est
vraiment pour moi salah des ternes
assemblage d'ingrédients d'hiver qui se
marient bien entre eux pour donner un
mélange facile et agréable avaler
lucioles tes réponses sont géniales faut
dire qu'à chaque fois là il ya trois
réponses inventer toutes pièces par
lucioles trop fort on va dire la
première voilà non ont passé un savon
corriger le savons est ici métaphore de
laver la bouche de quelqu'un qui a dit
des bêtises
will not dans les écoles françaises il y
avait une punition qui consistait à
lancer un blog de savon sur les élèves
dissipés et c'est ensuite devenu les
lancers de créer alors mec vraiment
pourquoi il y aurait du savon dans les
écoles
à un moment donné en pleine classe et tu
prends un bloc de savon dans la tête
c'est beaucoup trop violent
je sais pas à quelle école talent et
lucio là mais je ça m'a l'air très
violent tient son origine des lavoirs où
les femmes se retrouvaient pour laver le
linge au savon tout en me disant et
gossip ans sur le reste du village
non je crois le savon se faisait rare au
moyen-âge alors il était coutume de se
battre pour en obtenir
je n'en sais rien si l'asie à l'évasion
dire c'est la métaphore est celle avait
la bouche
yes he l'origine où les femmes se
retrouver pour lave linges et du coup a
sorti les petits gossip avoir les jetons
oui qu'est-ce que j'ai eue les jetons
sur sa chaîne youtube à multiples
reprises sur une petit jeu d'horreur
alors jetons découvrez ici de jeter et
en l'occurrence jeter les matières
fécales genre se chier dessus qu'en
lorraine mesure tes propos avoir les
jetons viendrait d'avoir peur de miser
au casino et donc de garder ses jetons
par précaution j'ai envie d'y croire
il allège pour lui il les garde parce
qu'il a peur c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ça je voulais que ce soit
ça donc j'ai choisi sa merde [ __ ] opus
la bonne réponse était plus de l'eau
gelée anglais en gros il a les jetons
dans son caleçon il allait rejet de son
corps dans son caleçon donc c'est chier
dessus parce qu'il a eu peur
ok j'espère ne plus jamais avoir les
jetons du groupe messieurs dames pour
ceux qui ont fait le quiz en même temps
que moi vous avez maintenant votre
petite note qui s'affiche à l'écran
bravo à tous ceux qui ont eu la moyenne
dont je fais partie pop-up bat avec je
viens collège g la moyenne c'est nul et
chiant ou doux et bien écoutez c'est la
fin de cette vidéo
avez vous apprécié moi j'ai surkiffé
peut-être trop par rapport à ce que
c'est alors je sais pas si j'aurai un
épisode si vous avez aimé peut-être mais
j'aimerais bien faire avec des guest
dans ce cas là pour débattre
d'ailleurs si vous allez rester vidéo à
plusieurs c'est comme vous avez pu
débattre et tout c'est bien moi en tout
cas c'est cool voilà j'aime bien ce truc
ça on apprend des trucs tout en
s'amusant et j'avoue que c'est un truc
qui m'a toujours plus la preuve j'ai
beaucoup de culture g ça montre que
j'apprends très régulièrement à l'air
bientôt on se tient au courant
tiens au courant terrible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]